ALICIA WILLIAMS: Your
mission-critical applications
depend on correct data.
That's why developers rely on
relational databases, which
ensure data consistency.
However, last
generation's databases
weren't designed to handle
today's scale and availability
requirements.
In today's episode,
we're talking
about how Spanner provides the
highest level of consistency
of any distributed relational
database at unlimited scale.
Consistency is one
of the main reasons
to choose a relational database
to back your applications.
Strong consistency
guarantees ensure
that data is correct,
regardless of
how it's accessed or updated.
Let's say you have a banking
system that transfers
money between accounts.
Consistency ensures
that the debit
from one account and the
credit into the other either
both succeed or both fail.
This simplifies
your applications
and lets your DBAs
sleep well at night.
When it comes time
to scale, however,
traditional relational
databases require
you to give up many of the
consistency protections
that made them attractive
in the first place.
This is because they
rely on techniques
like sharding to divide the
data across multiple instances.
The overhead required
to manage these shards
typically forces operators
to choose between performance
or consistency.
In addition, highly
available systems
need to maintain multiple
copies of the data in case
one of the shards goes down.
For many applications,
uncertainty
in the form of replication
lag or eventual consistency
is a recipe for complicated
code and tricky bugs.
This is where Cloud
Spanner can help.
Spanner is the only
distributed relational database
that provides external
consistency, the highest
consistency guarantee.
This means that all
changes in the database
appear from the outside as
if they happen sequentially.
This dramatically simplifies a
developer's view of the data.
No more sharded queries, timing
bugs, or compensating logic.
To your application,
Spanner looks
like a familiar
single-instance database.
It handles the
complexities of ensuring
consistent transactions,
even as infrastructure scales
up or automatically fails over.
Spanner is fully managed so
your operators don't ever
have to worry about
sharding or replication.
So how does Spanner provide
external consistency
without sacrificing availability
or performance at scale?
Let's start by
imagining your database
resides on a single machine.
In this case, it could
use a simple counter
to order incoming transactions.
However, a single machine
can only scale up so far.
Beyond that, you'll need
to distribute the work
across many machines.
Keeping a single
counter would be
a bottleneck between hundreds
or thousands of servers.
Spanner avoids this by
allowing each machine or node
to keep its own counter using a
clock, but not just any clock.
Using a combination of GPS,
atomic clocks, and Google's
dedicated fiber optic network,
Spanner's TrueTime technology
ensures accurate
ordering of transactions
without expensive
centralized coordination.
TrueTime simplifies
the work that Spanner
has to do to provide strict
external consistency.
This streamlining translates
to better performance
and higher availability for
strong ACID transactions.
Let's take a closer look at
how Spanner manages the data
involved in those transactions.
Spanner partitions
each table's data
into independent
chunks called splits.
Each split is assigned
internally to a server.
Unlike traditional
sharding, these splits
are completely transparent
to downstream users.
Spanner automatically optimizes
its split configurations
to balance out workloads
and avoid hotspots.
When a split is
under heavy load,
for example, when updating the
inventory of a popular product,
Spanner resizes and
re-balances the affected splits
to avoid overloading
individual servers.
Splitting and re-balancing
happen completely
behind the scenes,
dynamically adjusting based
on your data and workload.
To avoid a single
point of failure,
each split in a
regional instance
is replicated across
three isolated zones.
Spanner uses the well-known
Paxos consensus protocol
to ensure that everything
stays in sync, even
as the storage and
machines change underneath.
During a write, Spanner
first determines
which split or splits
will be affected.
Each split has a
leader among its copies
that coordinates
locking and replication.
The leader assigns a timestamp
to the transaction using
TrueTime and tells the replicas
about the updates using Paxos.
Once a majority of the replicas
acknowledge the update,
the leader directs them
to apply the changes
to the data at the
agreed-upon timestamp.
Leadership updates dynamically
within an instance,
again, to avoid single
points of failure.
For a query that doesn't
make any updates,
Spanner avoids
the extra overhead
of taking locks, accessing
an always consistent copy
of the data at the
most recent timestamp.
Combined, these optimizations
ensure consistency
and availability at scale.
Spanner takes
distributed consistency
a step further with
multi-region configurations.
Multi-region instances
replicate data
over two or three separate
geographic locations,
for example, the US,
Europe, and Asia.
This added replication,
up to nine times,
provides industry-leading
five nines of availability.
But doesn't all of this
come at a significant cost
to performance?
While, the underlying
work that Spanner
does to ensure consistency
and availability is not free.
You only pay a performance
cost for what you actually use.
In other words, if a query can
run without locking, it will.
Or if a write only
touches one split,
it will bypass a more
expensive two-phase commit.
This means that
your applications
will continue to
perform as they scale,
with all the same
consistency guarantees.
By partitioning the
data into splits,
Spanner can grow
beyond a single machine
and resolve queries in
parallel, improving scalability
and performance.
By replicating splits over
multiple zones and regions
connected by Google's
dedicated network,
Spanner is able to remain
highly available, up to 99.999%,
even under the most
grueling workloads.
Finally, by coordinating updates
using TrueTime and Paxos,
Spanner ensures that your
applications only ever see
a consistent view of the data.
The best part?
All of this is handled
transparently for you
behind the scenes.
So there you have
it, the magic sauce
behind Spanner's
consistency at scale.
Thank you for joining us today
for this episode of "Spanner--
Database Unlimited."
[MUSIC PLAYING]